the blast rocked the singapore flagged
oil tanker just after midnight
causing a fire and sending smoke
billowing into the sky
the bw rhine was parked up in jeddah's
port
its owner hafnia says all 22 sailors on
board
escaped unhurt
saudi-owned media reported that two
small boats were seen before the
explosion
it's the latest in a string of attacks
on saudi arabia's energy sector
mainly claimed by houthi rebels from
across the border in yemen
just three weeks ago the houthis fired a
missile which struck a petroleum plant
in jeddah
damaging a fuel storage tank the houthis
have been escalating their cross-border
strikes
to pile the pressure on the kingdom this
one is just seems to be just another one
of these attacks
against you know targets which are very
vital for saudi arabia you know as the
greatest exporter of royal in the world
um you know the babel mandep strait the
waters of the red sea are absolutely
crucially important for the oil price
and the the delivery of millions of
barrels of oil every every day so if you
make this
unsafe um that will have an impact on
saudi arabia security and that is
a very very high target and that
increases the urgency for saudi arabia
to do something about this yemen
conflict
the distance between yemen's shores and
the port of jeddah makes it difficult
but not impossible
for the houthis to send two small boats
filled with explosives
more than 600 kilometers to launch such
an attack
it could also have been carried out by
domestic operators
who often don't claim responsibility for
several days
so far no group has said it was behind
monday's blast
which saudi arabia's described as a
terrorist attack
there have been several violent
incidents in the country this year
last month in jeddah a bomb exploded at
a non-muslim cemetery
injuring several people this is a very
tricky
actions done by by by uh you know groups
or states
or other groups supported by states
and of course they don't claim you don't
find any evidence
and normally no one will would say i
have done this and this keep things
basically in a in
a gloomy uh situation for now
maritime authorities are urging vessels
in the area
to exercise extreme caution alexi
o'brien al jazeera